it was funny yesterday I met Steve
germanson one of the guys who started
Draper Fisher germanson funded Hotmail
on the bike trail you know right it's
like hey why don't you give me a call
and let's meet up and talk startups it's
like okay you know but here we have no
way to talk to our phone and say hey can
you talk to Steve germanson's phone and
right negotiate it I mean you could sort
of bump the phones and then get his
contact information you know or you can
you know text him or email him but you
can't really match up the system you
know and start say override everything
can you renegotiate my whole day because
I just got it sure
yeah and you can't do that then you got
to go back home and open up your browser
and start going man how can I screw this
person yeah sure you know how can I get
out of this thing you know and read
negotiate my dad you know and I have
accidental meetings all the time okay I
remember when I flew back from Microsoft
from it being interviewed at Microsoft I
met Larry Tessler
and we were both in the back row in a
Amer in a Alaska Airlines flight and you
you couldn't plan it right now but here
I had one of the top engineering Minds
in the world sitting next to me in the
back row you know you think he's up to
the first pass you know sure I mean he
was vice president of engineering at
Amazon at the time and uh he helped hire
Steve Jobs at Apple I mean it's just
okay
and there's my phone and um
and um
yeah it's stuff like that happens all
the time in my life and I look for it so
most people aren't most most people if
they sound like so Larry Tesla they sure
would have no idea they wouldn't have
that impulse to talk with it and ask him
what what do you do you know and I knew
he was a geek because of uh you know the
kind of computer he was using and stuff
like that I was like
you're strange what what's up right
what's up man I'm sitting next to two
guys just last week one guy had a
Windows XP machine and was using Excel
and one guy had an iPad and I was like
what's that you're doing something weird
what's going on what kind of apps do you
you know how I pull out my what kind of
apps do you have you know and I find out
he's a vice president of the computer
game company right these guys stand out
I mean why do they stand out because
they're innovators and they push things
they don't do what they did 10 years ago
you know they want a different idea they
want to try something new and that's the
kind of version I want to sit next to
not the guy who's on Excel you know
right I mean the Excel guy it could be
interesting if he's you know doing
something else but he's not breaking any
barriers not this guy right like an old
crappy Dell with Windows XP on it and
Excel and it's like no this guy doesn't
care about his his Computing life right
yeah and it'd be one thing if he had the
latest greatest Dell machine and windows
seven then at least we can say yeah
how's things going on with Windows 7
right financial apps but now this guy
was I've been doing this for 10 years I
don't need to change okay sure you're
not the kind of guy I'd like to talk to
and that's why I know we have to wrap up
but that's why I was asking you about
the likelihood to adopt something that's
entirely different right and that's the
Innovative component to say look I'm not
going to use the Old Dell with Windows
me and well that's why you have to if
you're going to do that you have to
skate where the puck will be and you
have to say and that's sort of why I
bring up Siri in this conversation so
much because we know they Apple bought
Siri we know from talking to because I
just interviewed the VCS that they're
put in charge of the next iPhone or the
iPhone strategy maybe not the next one
but the one after that so you're talking
you you know this that Apple's gonna
bring out a new iPhone every year
so we're talking next summer or the
summer after that right right that
they're going to integrate this in some
way I don't know what it's going to look
like I don't know how complete it's
going to be I don't know how cool it is
but Steve Jobs doesn't put stuff on
stage that's not cool right and so you
know
so skate where the Puck's gonna be okay
people are gonna have voice with a web
service hookup you know and it's gonna
negotiate with things and put things
places so you have a calendar other
people have other kinds of data types so
I can say hey I just found out I can go
to Steve durvitz's house tonight for
dinner
can you make that happen and that device
will make that happen sure no you can't
do that your wife has you uh with a
family dinner call a divorce lawyer yeah
I call divorce lawyer no okay uh can you
renegotiate with Steve jergensen for
some time that works for both of us you
know and and it could go off to his
Stevenson's calendar and go hey he's
open next weekend he's in town because
you guys know where we're actually gonna
be right and with Steve he's only here
in Half Moon Bay two days out of a 20.
you know so you got to find out when
he's going to be here or you got to go
and meet him where he is you know last
week he was shooting rockets in in the
desert you know that would have been
cool too you know it's like right it's
like can I come and shoot Rockets that's
fun but that's a different kind of
commitment to my calendar than going and
medium for dinner absolutely
yeah so that's what I'm saying is Skate
where the Puck's gonna be and you know
the iPad for instance right now right
now there's a window of opportunity this
summer
to ship these new ideas on the iPad
because the people who accept new ideas
like that guy sitting next to me are on
iPads and that's why Flipboard went
crazy right because everybody has this
iPad thing in front of them
not really sure why I spent 500 bucks on
this it's sort of cool and there's some
good games and I can watch Netflix
movies on it but
there's something coming well that's
that's skating where the Puck's gonna be
right I mean these guys saw oh the
iPad's coming out let's hire one of the
best designers from Apple yeah and let's
build a new kind of news experience for
the iPad and it comes out three months
after the iPad shifts and everybody's
hungry for a new idea yeah and boom you
know it hits yeah right and so
you know next year if this new iPhone
with this Siri thing comes out and
everybody's like oh that's cool what
else can we do with you know oh there's
only let's say there's a thousand apps
that use it well and I doubt there will
be a thousand ones that are really
optimized right today but if you come
out and say Hey you if you're on Siri
you can actually hook up your calendar
today and talk to your calendar and your
calendar will negotiate for you you know
stuff like that
then you'll get some scare because
you're sure you were out when everybody
was trying to discover a new idea or a
new thing right and same thing with
Google Google's got to do the same thing
right so if you make a deal with big
conductor and say hey man Google
Calendar is cool but you know right this
other thing right and it could make your
life a lot better king showed off on
stage maybe you know right you know and
then everybody's downloading or trying
out a tundle on their Android phone yeah
same thing we're going there now we got
to make them unfortunately okay
um Android app is coming yeah
um you've you've settled in just on a
more personal level uh with iPhone
that's I have a Samsung too I'm still
playing with it but I'm an iPhone guy I
mean you can start religious wars to me
it doesn't if you have a Samsung now
it's good it's a good enough phone right
right only five percent of my time is on
the phone right I'm doing this all day
long yeah so yeah I care about this not
about this and so people are like I care
about this I'm like yeah yeah I get a
second phone or buy an Android phone
appear you know
um the world is moving to where we're
doing more more of this and and it's
actually pretty good so and I you know I
just did a film on The Dead Zone on 92.
the freaking Samsung is just as bad you
know you hold your hand over it goes
from three bars to one right you know so
okay yeah it doesn't have the kind of I
mean I can get the thing to go to zero
here if I hold it right then but my
finger so it's sure it actually Bridges
the antennas but
did you see all the on the lines you
know it's sold out yeah yeah sold out
sold out in New Zealand in four hours
sold out in Australia but it doesn't
matter it the market sure doesn't matter
it's it's it's and it's actually Apple
and Google versus everybody else and
they're just gonna keep stealing market
share from everybody and
um one thing I'm hearing from a lot of
startups though is people on iPhones buy
buy apps and buy
um and buy things and Android users they
don't very interesting at a lower level
you know and yeah yeah OpenTable says
there are usage is way off off the
charts for iPhones for some reason and
it's like okay well yeah that sort of
makes sense because you're in the higher
end restaurants and so it's
self-selection but I hear that from eBay
from just other developers and and it's
like
the App Store I think in Google is sort
of broken there's something about it
that doesn't afford buying an app right
so free apps yeah there's they're
getting lots of downloads but people
aren't buying apps like they do for it
it's different market segments I think
it's importances
um how do I explain that
you know I've had Nokia phones for four
years that have had front-facing cameras
and I had video chat nobody's ever
called me in the middle and I said can I
try FaceTime with you right and try
right using a video
that they do want us and there's
something about the accordance of seeing
it one and also the marketing they've
they're showing you oh you can do this
video thing with this device Nokia never
really showed it to you right it really
made it sexy yeah you know and so they
didn't impel you to do it with the
marketing and but it's also the afford
it I can click here and get and it works
and I don't need to have the guy on the
other hand load something like I did on
Nokia right if I wanted to play with it
I'd have to load somebody a conferencing
software and I'd have to make sure he
had it
and here in the United States nobody has
no kid phones very nice you know it
would always be the Europeans but it
just didn't never worked and I never had
that inference week just click on
something and make it happen and this
thing does and so and I think that's
what Steve Jobs
building that affordance and like if I'm
gonna add a new feature to it it's going
to be usable and everybody's going to
want to click on it and try
and it's going to do something that
that's why Siri I think was so
attractive to him it's like
although the market perceived that as a
search play right initially
it was a search product wasn't it it's
not really search it's different because
it doesn't search web pages it searches
apis it it negotiates with apis it's
really a bit more accurate answer
the problem is
um I when I saw him I mean they were
here in the South they pitched me and
it's like you're gonna get bought
seriously okay yeah I said you're going
to get bought within months because it's
too strategic for you to be on the
street
um your idea is going to make some big
company uh a lot of money and and you're
going to get by and that was right but I
never used it that much because it just
is not that satisfying because there's
not enough apis in my dashboard for a
long time yeah I mean I I'm actually
starting to use it again because I'm
trying to think about where this one
where it could go where is Apple and did
you see the patent Apple's patenting yes
that's all about Siri
look at the at the screens they're
putting in they're putting in like
negotiation kinds of screens yeah like
hey would you like a pizza right now
yeah and that's Siri there and they
didn't put it in the UI of Siri but I'm
like I'm reading into that and going
okay they're patenting Concepts that are
going to come out in a future Series so
that they can protect it against Google
you know or against Nokia and have some
you know they have some playing cards on
the table and Nokia Susan again because
no kids out of it out of the game sure
it's just out of here
if they don't figure this out within the
next six months they're a lot of the
game because that Google has voice and
appalach's voice and Nokia
they have an ugly UI and their voice
doesn't work right
user sees a Google or an Apple phone and
you're talking to it yeah and it's doing
yeah you want I want that phone and
I don't want it and my phone sucks
I mean imagine when you got voice search
yeah well and when you have enough API
right now it only has 40 apis right
exactly imagine a world where it has a
hundred thousand apis and you can just
that you can talk with and you can talk
to every app like and you can ask it
like what was the difference between my
ride time yesterday and the ride time
Tuesday yeah and did I see any
difference or what's the difference in
my heart rate or what's the difference
and it comes back with an answer because
that data's there
then tell it you know what's the average
rainfall in movement
July 15th because it finds it for you
and brings back a graph of every July
15th forever you know I mean I've done
that kind of search right
there you if you're buying a house you
you should be on well for that if I go
for sure you know what what's the
average wealth of each neighborhood you
know where can I afford to live you know
go to Zillow where what's the average
housing price where's I can afford a 900
000 house where where can I buy a house
right now you know and it should bring
heat maps to the city and say this is
these are the four areas you should
focus your searching on you know then
you go to realtor.com and circle and
then it shows you all the houses for
sale in that neighborhood yeah yeah
indeed anyways thank you so hopefully
this helped oh yeah great